what do you think is going on zoobee
i think we're living through a period of
moral panic
mass psychosis
mass formation
and overall confusion and i think what's
particularly strange is that this is
happening pretty much on a global scale
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people doesn't get any better than who
we have for you today he's an author
rapper and podcaster and a friend of the
show zooby welcome back bro how you
doing always good man happy to be back
it's good to have you back listen we
seem to get you in i think the first
time we spoke we're probably one of the
first people to do a long form interview
with you uh then uh the world went crazy
last year over the whole blm thing we
had you and then and we've got you back
now give us some sanity please what
we sort of feel like we have to get you
in to give us you've been commenting on
the covert thing extensively from the
very beginning
what do you think is going on zoobee
i think we're living through a period of
moral panic
mass psychosis
mass formation
and overall confusion and i think what's
particularly strange is that this is
happening pretty much on a global scale
actually over the past 18 months i've
traveled to seven different countries i
spent a lot of time out in the usa as
you guys saw i went to 10 different
states beyond that i've been to turkey
mexico portugal
greece
romania
and the uk of course
and
it's weird to have
this might be the first time in history
actually where the entire world
has been going through the same thing
at the same time and everybody is
interconnected and able to communicate
with each other and all of that if you
think of it when things happen normally
they're fairly localized to a certain
country or region
but with this whole situation this whole
pandemic and the response to the
pandemic which
the secondary part to me personally has
been far more concerning from the
beginning
it's weird that no matter where you go
whatever city whatever country wherever
you are
you can say
kovid or the pandemic or whatever and
everyone knows exactly what you're
talking about it's the same word in
every single language it's coveted
everywhere and everyone knows what that
means and you can't really
you you can't escape it actually but
it's virtually everywhere and and one of
the points you said is mass psychosis
and all of that
i mean there is a pandemic right there
is a disease there's a disease yeah yeah
so there's a lot of people who who would
take issue with that obviously and they
would say well there's a global pandemic
we had to respond to it in in the in in
every way to save lives uh that's the
argument that people have been putting
forward a lot to me and to you sure
online etc so what do you say to those
people well that's based off of the
assumption
and the conclusion
that the measures
and response
has been a net positive
and has saved more lives
than it's either
directly or indirectly killed let alone
harmed i mean how do you measure
how do you actually measure life saved
how do you measure harm caused how do
you measure
the damage caused to people's mental and
physical health missed cancer treatments
and
diagnoses i guess those can be
quantified well just to interrupt you
very briefly there was an article in the
telegraph which will pop up on the
screen uh there's three quarters of a
million missed cancer diet up to three
quarters of a million miss cancer
diagnosis in the uk
okay alone so that's about what five
times as many as the official death
count right from
with covid yeah um
yeah so that's just and that's just
cancer what about the damage cost to
children what about the effects of
unemployment inflation mental health
suicide depression there are a lot of
factors there's a lot of stuff
that
has been going on so if you're going to
talk about any measure and this is what
i was sort of screaming from the
beginning you have to weigh up pros and
cons we're still living in this time
where
look
when it comes to lockdowns and mass
mandates
and one could even argue vaccination
rates to some extent depending on which
countries you're looking at
there is no solid strong evidence
that lockdowns
have helped to save
lives it's very
fuzzy if you look at the usa you look
state to state you've got 50 different
countries which all implemented
different lockdown policies there's no
correlation between
the lockdowns and the death rates per
million even if you were to look at a
country like sweden
within europe which didn't do a lockdown
and you compare it say to the uk sweden
never had a lockdown never had a mass
mandate
throughout this whole thing
sweden i believe has
lower death per million number than the
uk does if you look at the entire
continent of africa
five percent vaccination rate maybe not
even up to
54 countries
poor health care systems in general
compared to the west poor infrastructure
um
a lot many places didn't really do very
hard lockdowns many places never had
mass mandates
the entire continent of africa i believe
has approximately according to official
stats the same death count as the uk
66 million versus 1.4 billion
well i don't know the what's the uk
vaccination rate 80
plus versus 5
so these are
huge
things that don't
make sense based off of what one would
expect now i'm a very pro liberty person
even if lockdowns and mass mandates were
somewhat effective
i would not be in favor of them being
mandated by the force of the state
however it's an extra slap in the face
when people are promoting these policies
and you can look at it at this we've got
two years of data from all these
different countries and you can't show
me a strong correlation between either
lockdowns or mass mandates and
hospitalization rates infection rates
death rates
people always want it to do something i
think it's natural for human beings to
think that you you can't just do nothing
right like you've got there's a threat
here
and you the answer cannot be
do nothing or keep calm carry on right
which is actually ironically that's
finally what the uk was going to do to
begin with and then boris got covered
himself and i think he got spooked and
the media was pressuring him so he kind
of copycatted what was going on
elsewhere whereas countries like sweden
and i believe a couple others like
albania um
they were like no we're not
going to do this we're it doesn't it
doesn't make sense based on previous
pandemic protocols they're looking at
the numbers and the science itself
they're like okay this is the group
that's vulnerable
okay this group is not vulnerable this
is the infection fatality rates so on
and so forth looking at the actual data
looking the science itself and going
okay the response has to be
proportionate and i think
disproportionate
has been
one one of the key words that struck me
here disproportionate and precedent i
think a lot of the precedents that have
been set are extraordinarily dangerous
because people also have to remember
look we're supposed to live in free
countries one of the best things about
the western world
western europe usa canada australia new
zealand all of that has been freedom and
liberty and the fact that people do have
individual rights and that they are free
to generally make their own choices so
on and so forth i'm glad that you've
used the past tense for those statements
[Laughter]
well look this is this is the dream we
were all sold right so
that is
it's been weird to me to see in these
countries
how
loosely and easily people have been
willing to just jettison that because
they're afraid
right it's like no that that still
matters and people like to just go to
well look this many people have died if
you're in the usa people scream you know
but 700 000 americans have died people
say 440 000 people in the uk have died
five million worldwide
firstly
those numbers are sketchy okay we don't
actually know how many people have died
of covid directly from it to this day we
actually don't have a clue
which is concerning i think we should
know that by now there should be some
kind of audit the reason you're saying
that is because many of the deaths have
been people who had coveted yes but they
did not there's no evidence necessarily
that they died of covet in fact in this
country again this has been covered
extensively in the media there was a
long period of time that covert deaths
was anybody
who died having been diagnosed positive
for coverage if you got diagnosed
positive for covered without any
symptoms walked out of the hospital got
hit by a bus yes you died of covered yes
deaths within 28 days of a positive test
right i think that's still how it's
counted um i think at some point it was
90 days within a positive now to show
people just how absurd that is to
quantify it okay let's talk about um the
sacred cow is is the vaccine right you
know no one's allowed to criticize
vaccines etc if i were and this is not
my position by the way and this is not
how i would ever count it but i'm using
this to make the example if somebody who
is skeptical or cautious or even full-on
anti-vex which is a very very small
minority of people
and they were trying to
tell you that the vaccine is dangerous
and they said and the way that they
counted vaccine deaths or
deaths was
a death within 28 days of taking a
vaccine
what would people say
they'd say that you're being
disingenuous mate come on but that's how
they count the covert death that's the
official way
so you could say that that's a maximum
so you could say in the uk at most
around 150 000 deaths what percentage of
that is
from covid directly versus with i don't
know i think in terms of the
comorbidities you're talking about 90
plus of those deaths involved other
comorbidities that doesn't necessarily
mean that that person couldn't have died
from covid but of course this can
include you know people being diabetic
having various types of cancers all
sorts of different illnesses which are
factored in there and also you have to
look at the age as well so again if
you're talking about
you know
when people are looking at figures and
facts you have to you have to
contextualize them
so if you're going to say that
you know so a lot of people say zooby
look 5 million people worldwide have
died of this disease in the past two
years
firstly
i two two important ways to
contextualize that number one number one
question i'd ask is what was the average
age of death
okay so in the uk i believe the average
age of death was around
82. it was here okay which is about the
average life expectancy
so that does matter is this me saying
that
you know old people should die i
wouldn't know it's not any of that right
i know lots of elderly people whom uh i
care about and i love the point is that
human beings do not live forever life
has a hundred percent mortality rate
okay so someone in in normal times
somebody who is 85 years old dying of
something
is is sad death is always sad
but it's not
um
it's not a tragedy
in the way that a 22 year old or a 12
year old dying is where their huge
amount of their life has been cut short
and it feels very unfair if someone
lives to
honestly 70 plus you'd say okay they've
had a decent decent fair innings
so we were not immortal prior to 2020
and some people seem to have forgotten
that the next point i'd make on that is
just re people don't aren't aware of i
don't think people are generally aware
of how many people die every year in the
uk alone about 1 500 people die every
day
every day 1 500 okay so when we were
here earlier in the year and they're
talking about we've had 15 coveted
deaths today
it's 15 out of 1500
deaths that's
again every every death is sad it's all
sad but the fact that 90 of the focus is
on that 15 and people aren't even aware
of those other ones on a global scale
about 60 million people worldwide die
every year 60 million so if you're gonna
say that five million people have died
let's
let's say all five million died of covid
five million out of
maybe 110 to 120 million deaths and then
you look at the way
people respond to that versus respond to
everything else and there are other
viral diseases out there sure the
biggest killers are heart disease and
cancer but there are other things which
are also transmissible but the way
people respond
is not the same it's almost like
implicitly people have decided
that not only is kovid more important
than every other threat and also more
important than civil liberties and more
important than freedom and more
important than happiness and mental
health and livelihoods
also that if you die from it somehow
that is more tragic
and more important
than all the other things that somebody
could get sick or injured or die from
that that seems to be the unwritten and
unsaid narrative
throughout this thing that's then used
to justify everything else that covet is
the
most important thing in every country
right if we have to sacrifice all these
other things for it
then it's worth it because this is the
most important thing and that
conversation was never had it was just
assumed it's actually more of a
philosophical question and everything
sort of is downstream of that idea
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
ridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anthem has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
the civil liberties thing i find so
interesting the fact that we've just
been able to go you know what these
don't matter let's get rid of the right
to protest let's get rid of the right to
congregate
let's get rid of the right for people to
actually buy alcohol and to at one point
they told the scots they weren't allowed
to buy alcohol
it felt like we were genuinely being
trolled do you remember when they said
that
it did it did you remember that moment
where they said yeah if you're going to
have sex wear a mask yeah yeah or when
you could have um
what was you had to have a substantial
meal when they reopened pubs temporarily
and uh
you you had to have a meal it could have
the scotch it was the scotch egg gate
wasn't there yeah
where you could have a substantial meal
but once you finish your meal you can't
order
alcohol you can drink alcohol with your
meal but not outside of it because kovid
yeah but
people just abandoned the right to
protest and they didn't even give it a
second thought the only moment when
everyone woke up was when uh after the
sarah everard murder you had that
women's vigil and then the police went
to break it up oh yeah and things got a
bit you know it's got a bit out of hand
that's when people woke up but before
that people were fine yeah it's so
worrying it's it's the power of fear
it's really the power of fear and
something i've been thinking a lot about
this a lot because to me what's really
interesting about this whole situation
and i think why i talk about it a lot is
the the psychology
really understanding the psychology of
course there's virology and there's
epidemiology and as people like to
remind me i'm not i'm not a doctor and i
don't have a medical degree i have the
same medical qualifications as bill
gates to be honest
um
and in fact the same as many of the
health ministers i'd say i have better
qualifications than some of them but
i've been thinking a lot about fear and
just individual and collective human
psychology because
this is really what's been at play here
and i think that the powers that be in
the media in politics because this whole
thing has been heavily politicized in
every country they're really preying
upon that they're preying upon this fear
emotion that human beings have they're
preying upon
people's desire for social status
they're preying upon um
people's desire to fit in and not to be
socially
ostracized or to be the one who's the
odd one out or to be different and
they've really weaponized all of these
things and
the most dangerous and despicable thing
they're doing actually there's a lot of
them i think one of them i think what
they're doing to children is very
despicable um but i think one of the
most insidious things that i've seen
going on and i predicted this happening
was this demonization of the
unvaccinated right turning people
against each other i think people do
have a right to be angry and people do
have a right to feel frustrated after
all some people have been locked in
their houses unable to depending on
where you live in the world unable to
leave your region or your country or see
your friends or family abroad for two
years so i think people do have a right
to be angry and feel frustrated but what
they've done is they've taken that
energy and instead of people being mad
at the people who have actually
inflicted this upon them
they're being trained
to blame
their neighbors that is a really good
point and this is the point see because
i'm going to ask you why you think
they're doing all of this but before
maybe let me just say this because that
is such a good point and this is what
i've been saying throughout the reason
politicians
are fueling this
is not in my opinion some great big
conspiracy is just that they recognize
that every person who dies of covid
under their watch is gonna get pinned on
them yes whereas every person who dies
of cancer three years later because
their their diagnosis got missed isn't
yes and so what they're doing is they
are saying
these people who haven't taken the
vaccine or who don't wear the mask or
whatever they are the reason all of this
happening and it works brilliantly for
politicians because what it means is the
blame
isn't on them it gets shifted on to
these other people who can be
scapegoated as if they're somehow
responsible for the pandemic or the
lockdowns or the other stuff that the
government is doing however zooby
you've detailed all of the terrible
things that have happened in the last
two years which i personally entirely
agree with what you've said
why is it happening
well
there's this
it depends on how deep someone wants to
go on this really
okay if we're going to talk about a
government
okay so let's let's talk about some of
the big key actors here let's talk about
pharmaceutical companies let's talk
about
governments
and let's talk about
the media say
so what is the role what's the role of a
government the role of a government is
to
exert control
power and authority to some degree
depending on your personal political
views you may differ on how much power
and the scope of that
how big you think that should be
and so when it comes to politicians we
all know
all throughout human history all across
the world
modern times are not particularly unique
that these individuals
exist to
seek power and control and to exert
authority over other human beings right
i'm not a full-blown anarchist so i'm
not saying that that should exist to no
degree whatsoever
but that's what they do right that's
what they're campaigning for whether
you're a mayor or you're a governor or
you're even a school monitor
or you're let alone a president or a
prime minister that that's your that's
your job that's your role and the more
you can get people to invest in that
idea
then the more votes you can win and the
more you can maintain control and
authority
so
that is their aim the the goal of the
government and the goal of politicians
isn't necessarily to
care about you or to take care of your
health or your family's health or to do
this or to that or for you to be happy
they want they care about your votes and
they care about your
taxes of course and so
typically if you have a a decent
politician they're not going to be
uh
you know they're not going to a full
fully 100 tyrannical because that will
ultimately result in some type of revolt
so when it comes to government entities
power control and authority and seizing
that is nothing unique i mean let's look
at history let's look around the world
let's look at the current world
people like power that's just how it is
there's people who are wired that way
some people are more authoritarian than
others and when you give them power they
typically don't like to let go of it
even if it's a very very minor amount
so
that's the power and control aspect
because that has been so centralized and
under these emergency powers which they
can keep rolling over as they've done
they have power to do things that
typically during time they do not so i
think that's something that's just very
clear
what's the job of a major multinational
corporation
make money to make money right nothing
wrong with that i'm a capitalist right
as long as you're doing it ethically
nothing wrong with that you have a
product you want to sell your product or
your service to people who willingly
want to buy it so
when you're talking johnson and johnson
pfizer modern all of these companies
um
they they want to sell as many
of their of their injections as possible
they want to sell as much as possible of
course they've got these governmental
contracts with these different
governments around the world and some
people miss this when they talk about
the vaccine being free it's like no
that's coming out of the taxpayer money
by the way countries like the uk ordered
seven shots per person
per person including children just for
2021 so the amount of surplus is uh is
crazy
and so
this has been one of the most profitable
time periods for them i mean these
companies are making money hand over
fist
through all of this now if this were all
based on voluntary activity i have no
problem with that whatsoever right i'm
not against pharmaceuticals or against
medicine or whatever
i buy medicine sometimes i get sick i
need this cool i'm gonna go buy that but
when it comes to this being in bed with
the governments and then the mandating
of you be must become a pfizer or modern
customer in order to have your freedom
or your rights back whatever like you're
moving into the realm of actual fascism
not
fascism in the way people
mess around with it and this is being
enforced that's really where you are
you're no longer in any type of realm of
capitalism so
the profit motive is
super obvious i mean and
as as i said before it's not inherently
a bad thing having a profit motive but
in this type of situation it can lead to
all types of unethical behavior and i
think it also explains whether you're
talking about suppression of other
treatments or you're talking about
certain elements of censorship or you're
talking about things like natural
immunity not being discussed or you're
talking about trying to force these
shots on a population speaking
specifically of children who you know
are not and never have been at high risk
from this particular virus yet there's
this insane again very disproportionate
push for everybody to do this now it was
announced yesterday they want to get
people on a three-month booster campaign
so people are taking four injections a
year has there ever been a time in
history where a healthy person let alone
everybody needs to take four injections
a year like that's just just think about
that that's unprecedented that's normal
but that's a lot of money that's a lot
of money for these companies it's a
subscription model i'm an entrepreneur i
know that the best there's nothing
better than a subscription model right
join our locals
yeah and then moving to the media
companies again they're they're
companies right their their job is to
make money attention eyeballs we know
that fear sells in the media they have
that saying if it bleeds it leads if you
can get people afraid whether it's a war
it's a virus it's climate change
whatever if people are fearful you get
them to click you get them to buy you
get more advertising revenue and so on
the big orange boogeyman is gone now so
you need another thing to freak people
out about
once they finish this one you can
already see they're moving back into the
climate change
hysteria now they call it the climate
emergency or climate crisis because fear
fear does
it sells and if you can keep people in
that state so i think that at the at the
minimum to me
money
power
control and
authority
that explains a lot of things now you've
made the point and you've used the word
fascism to describe
mandating factions which i'm entirely on
board with and i think is consistent
with the values of fascism but why is it
that nobody talks about it why is it you
get people like ursula van der leyen a
mainstream well-known german politician
defense german defense minister that's
who you want mandating vaccines yeah and
who comes out and basically goes you
must take as a vaccine and we're going
to mandate it yeah
why is that not controversial
it's because people have been led here
very slowly it's happened quickly but
slowly at the same time
right it's been
what i call a compliance ladder
this is something you can even learn in
in sales it's really a sales technique
which is you start with a very small ask
you have to i like to just think back to
i don't know february 2020 and just
remember
what the narrative was at the beginning
what the initial request was and it all
starts with things that you can't you
know
it's very very minor it's a it's an
escalation so it started with
you know
wash your hands
of course everybody 100 100 of course
all right wash your hands and then it
was um ooh stand six feet apart practice
social distancing normally i've noticed
that a three word notice the three word
phrases wash your hands six feet apart
um then it would stay at home stay at
home is a pretty big ask
because that's unprecedented people have
never really been told to do that before
not in our lifetimes but again it was
like okay but then you know and it was
explained it grant flattened the curve
we need enough time to get ppe we need
enough time to get ventilators that's
how it was all explained so everyone's
like you know what
look if that's that's a that's a
reasonable request that was me i i was
fully oh yeah and i'm not i'm not
criticizing anyone for being on board
with that then um as time went on you
started to get some
some weird requests clap for the nhs
that was a weird one that was very
ritualistic you know this time every
week like a sunday service people come
out and
you know start doing this behavior i'm
not going to get into them firing
healthcare workers yeah but like
that that was that was an odd thing but
you you you know you had a lot of people
participating in that but it's just been
step by step by step and then the the
goal posts
have shifted and shifted and shifted
right
people forget people actually totally
forgotten what the purpose of lockdowns
was the purpose of lockdowns initially
was never to reduce the total number of
deaths it was to spread it out so that
the hospitals wouldn't get overwhelmed
because they thought okay if everyone
if 50 of the population gets infected at
the same time you're going to have tons
of excess debts because the hospitals
are all going to be blocked and people
are going to be dying unnecessarily of
all sorts of things so it was okay we're
not going to reduce the total number of
infections and deaths but let's flatten
the curve and reduce that
let's let's reduce the rate right and so
now
this has been another is one of they've
been so many slights of hand but the
sleight of hand now is that lockdown
save lives it's like wait that was never
that was never the purpose of them
that was never actually the purpose of
them so now people repeat that and
they've kind of memory hold what that
initial flat and the curve thing was all
about and then they've done this on all
different things so i'm not sure if they
specifically said this in the uk but
certainly in the usa president biden
himself
and rochelle wolinski the director of
the cdc both said at the beginning of
this year that if you get the vaccine
you will not get covet and you will not
transmit covid right they claimed it was
a sterilizing vaccine if you take the
shot won't do it
now what's the narrative on them
prevents severe deaths sorry prevents
prevents severe illness and uh and death
that's a
that's a really different thing and this
is within less than less than 12 months
so a lot of people i mean there are
people to this day who still think that
it stops
transmission and it stops infection and
that's what again that's what all this
narrative is based on so there are
certain myths or outright lies that this
is based on you know you have the whole
asymptomatic transmission thing act like
you've got it you know there's
asymptomatic
again lord fauci himself said that
asymptomatic transmission is not a major
driver of any pandemic and now
everything all these policies were from
the masking to the social it's all based
on the notion that all of us at all
times could be sick and everyone around
you could be sick and could could
transmit it so you've got everybody
acting like they're ill
when there's no reason to believe that
they are and again this is unprecedented
this has never been done before and so
they keep moving the goalposts they've
been all these slights of hand and and i
think
each time it happens
and and when you have the media support
as well and the media is not asking
these questions like i just ask a lot of
questions i have a long memory and i ask
a lot of questions and i ask for
explanations but the people in the media
the so-called journalists are not
willing to do that either because
they're on the payroll or maybe they're
just afraid or whatever it is and so you
don't get these answers when
sorry what do you mean on the payroll
who's payroll
matt
pharmaceutical companies
for one
and governments depending on which
organizations we're we're talking about
i mean pfizer spot using the sponsored
by pfizer sponsored by pfizer good
morning america is brought to you by
pfizer cbs watch sponsored by pfizer
anderson cooper 360.
brought to you by pfizer abc news
nightline
brought to you by pfizer making a
difference
brought to you by pfizer cnn tonight
brought to you by pfizer early start
brought to you by pfizer friday night on
aaron burnett out front brought to you
by pfizer this week with george
stephanopoulos is brought to you by
pfizer this weather report brought to
you by pfizer today's countdown to the
royal wedding is brought to you by
pfizer and now a cbs sports update
brought to you by pfizer meet the press
data download brought to you by pfizer
this portion of cbs this morning
sponsored by pfizer on how to find the
hidden sugars in the american family
diet sponsored by pfizer in the usa the
big pharma companies run man they
they're in bed with
so many people in congress i think they
have over i think
i mean i'm pretty sure don't don't quote
me on this but isn't it like fi pfizer
alone has something like 100 lobbyists
in the us government let i think there's
several there's several hundred big
pharma lobbyists
within the us government and then so
many stocks are held by these
politicians and then they're sponsoring
the media channels uh whether you're
talking
they've got their money in cnn and in
cbs and all these companies they've
they've got their money
they've got their money everywhere
um and that's
that's a conflict of interest
i mean of course that that's a huge
conflict of interest the um executive
director of reuters itself
is a um he believes he's a board member
at pfizer i believe or or a he's he's
either a board member or one of their
sort of top investors and and
stakeholders that's a very obvious
conflict of interest um same when you've
got guys like fauci and the whole thing
it's just this web is this is this
entangled web
of everyone sort of being behind the
same thing and so that's why you're not
there's really obvious questions that
are not being asked and there's really
huge elements of science itself and
immunology itself that are being totally
ignored if you want to see
a huge one and
you know the denial
or the unwillingness to talk about
natural immunity i don't know why people
don't talk about it right but we've
we've both had covered and people are
trying to get us to take a vaccine to
give us antibodies that we already have
which are stronger which are known to be
stronger yes and exactly so
at this point hundreds of millions of
people have had this virus hundreds of
millions right it's not it's not march
2020 anymore right it's december 2021
and so the unwillingness to even talk
about that or address the series to me i
mean there's a lot of red flags but that
that's just a huge glaring red flag and
so look when i view this thing through
the lens of health and safety and
protecting people from a virus there's a
lot of things that don't make sense
whether you're talking the denial of
natural immunity or you're talking about
why someone wants you to wear a mask to
enter three steps into a restaurant just
for you to take it off again for an hour
which by the way
they're doing all over the world without
question right if you view it through
health and safety it makes no sense if
you view it through like i said before
money power and control
it all makes sense right because if you
deny if you're trying to sell as many
shots as possible you're going to go for
the kids you're going to go for people
who've already had it you're going to
you're going to try to get people on a
subscription model you're going to do
whatever is necessarily there and that's
to me where it's deeply unethical you
will suppress and not want to talk about
other treatments right that's another
thing that's been
mind-blowing the complete suppression
about other treatments have you noticed
that no one talks about treatment
right no one no one even talks about
treatment like what do you do if you do
get covet and you want to recover what
do you do right you have to go search on
you know murky depths of the internet to
find that out and
that's
very very unethical and it's very
concerning so that's why someone like me
looks at this and is like look this is
not simply about health and sale
man you can go on forever have they
talked about vitamin d have they talked
about zinc have they talked about losing
body fat have they talked about going
outside and getting sunlight all right
here's the thing it's been two years man
we know this is something that mostly
affects people who are overweight you've
had two years in which you could have
been telling people lose weight here's a
government program to help you lose
weight here's some money to encourage
you to lose weight if this is about
health
why don't we make this about making
people healthy and in fact they did the
opposite they shut down the gyms yeah
they stopped you from going outside
they um
they they closed the gyms they they
opened mcdonald's and kfc
and all of that so they offered you a
free burger with fries to go and get
vaccinated so it's it's not even just
that it's like they did the opposite and
a scratch card yeah
that got you excited yeah
the gambling addict
yeah they've they've done the opposite
and and these are low real low hanging
fruit again why would you deny vitamin d
majority of people who died with kovid
were vitamin d deficient
right do you remember last year when
they were talking about um black people
being more susceptible yeah and they ran
with all the racism narratives and stuff
and it's like black people are more
likely to be vitamin d deficient
and so in a disease
that is particularly rough for people
who are vitamin d deficient and you have
a segment of the population who due to
the melanin content of their skin
like is more likely to be vitamin d
deficient like if you want to talk about
actual racism
not talking about that
is actual racism right and people are
there like acting like this is basic
stuff as people again as people like to
remind me i'm not a doctor so why am i
the one who knows this basic information
and is willing to put it out there i was
talking about vitamin d back in like
april 2020 because i myself just every
winter need to supplement with it or i'm
more likely to get sick even with colds
etc and i just don't feel very well so
it's and it's cheap and but that's the
problem right there's no there's no
money to be made from it so i think that
we have seen
profit
and the desire for power and for control
being put up being put over human lives
and human well-being which is why i find
it extraordinarily funny but also kind
of tragic when people look at someone
like myself or maybe someone like
yourselves who are critical of some of
the policies due to the downstream
repercussions of them and people accuse
us of being people who are selfish or we
don't care about lives we don't care
about it's like
no like that's not the situation and the
people who have been really trying to
ram all these policies one thing i
noticed they have in common is that
they're hardly affected by them
and that they've been getting paid all
the way through is anyone in the media
has any politician taking a pay cut
during all of these lockdowns and all
these stay at home more than no they've
been earning their money as usual
they've been flaunting many of the rules
themselves they have not they've
suffered some of the least from it
so it's um
the one the thing that i always find
worrying is the effect it has had on
small businesses the amount of small
businesses that have shut as a result of
these lockdowns the amount of businesses
that have gone to the wall which then
leaves a gap in the economy which is
going to be filled right by what huge
multi yeah huge multinational
conglomerates yeah absolutely hasn't
blackrock been buying up all these uh
derelict
empty properties i believe i believe
someone might want to verify this i
believe that 70 percent of restaurants
in calif in uh
is it california or los angeles
specifically have um shut down yeah well
see i want to address something because
as we're doing interviews nowadays
because of the world we live in i have
this sort of like low iq voice filter
where i just imagine what a stupid
person would would hear out of what
we're saying okay
so we should address this
i imagine because this is how i think
about it and i imagine you'd agree with
me that the reason you're talking about
the profit motive power and all of this
is not because you think some people got
together in a smoke-filled room with
cigars and went you know what guys we're
going to make billions we're going to
create a pandemic and then we're going
to take advantage of it and then this
and that i just think what happens is
when people have incentives i i believe
this is how the world works people
respond to incentives so if you're
making a product like a vaccine
the the motivation for that is
undoubtedly to save lives in my opinion
then they came up with this thing to
help people that's what the
pharmaceutical companies did but now
that you've made it and you're saving
lives well of course you want to save as
many lives as possible and the fact that
it seems to be making you more money
well great because you're saving that's
a reflection of how many lives you're
saving and that's the sort of
calculations people make and politicians
are the same you know
we are saving lives so we need more
power so we can save more lives they're
not they're not sitting there thinking
with some kind of evil intent i don't
think i don't know
you don't know i think it depends on who
you're talking about i think every
individual is different
i think that there are many people who
have malicious intent or extreme what
makes you say that
because that's human beings there are
bad people
bad people exist
right not everyone and as a good natured
you know decently moral person
it's extraordinarily hard to kind of
accept
that there are
bad people with bad intentions out there
for example if you are if you are a sane
reasonable decent person
you cannot get into the mind of a serial
killer you can't do it
because it's so far removed you might be
able to say i don't know a terrorist or
someone who kills for some type of cause
as much as you disagree with it and
condemn it you can understand you might
be able to with a high degree of empathy
understand their thinking but someone
who's just a psychopathic serial killer
you cannot because they're just
bad right they're just malicious and so
and i think that when you move into
higher certain areas you get a higher
percentage of psychopaths right i do
believe that in politics i do believe
that um very high up in certain
corporations etc you're going to get
more people
who have psychopathic tendencies do i
think that's the majority no
i don't think it's the majority but i do
think that there are people out there
who genuinely do not give a crap about
human life they do not care about your
well-being they do not care about your
health they do not care about you in the
slightest
they care about power they care about
money and we've seen these figures
throughout history they exist they're
real people all right
we can we can name them right these are
people and and they've often reached the
highest positions
of power
right
you know hitler was a bad dude stalin
bad dude mussolini
bad dude mel yep like so of course
they're going to guys it is this is some
greater good and this is for your health
and this is your well-being you know
saddam hussein right like there are bad
people who do exist
um and so i think that we have to
acknowledge that and then i think
outside of that
most people
it's simply
like you said it's it's simply
incentives and i think that it's i
believe that most to
on on the contrary of what i just said i
do believe that most people have good
intentions
right so i'm not saying that oh everyone
is trying to you know i think most
people have good intentions but people
can be misled people can be led by um
ideology people can be led by just
social pressures and the desire to
conform people can just be led by um
threat of punishment right fear people
people are acting in fear right you've
got people look i mean i'd love to know
again talk about the sacred cow i would
be interested to see
how many people took these shots
because they specifically truly thought
it was the best thing for them for their
for their health and their well-being
versus how many people took it due to
pressure and coercion or wanting to
visit family abroad or whatever yeah i i
wouldn't classify that i'd call that i'd
call that pressure i'd put that
yeah yeah that's what i mean yeah i'd
put that in the lighter category it
would be interesting to to see i think
again i think early on look if if people
didn't want me to be skeptical about us
it would what would have made sense is
if they just
you know rolled the rolled these out and
pushed not mandated it pushed and
promoted it towards people over 60
especially those with comorbidities and
perhaps um under 60 with comorbidities
and strongly recommended it
and
then
chilled out i think that would make a
lot of people
way less
skeptical of the whole thing now it's
like whoa you're gunning at the
five-year-olds now
has a single healthy five-year-old
anywhere in the world died of this virus
i'm not aware of a single child healthy
child i'm not aware of a single
otherwise healthy child anywhere in the
world who's died of this particular
virus i'm not saying it hasn't happened
i'm not aware of one i haven't heard
haven't heard a single story not one
not one
so what are we
what are you doing because this is a
very age stratified disease we've known
this from very very early if you're 75
years old with comorbidities versus your
10 years old with no comorbidities to
treat it like it's the same
is
insane this goes with all the measures
all the policies to treat it like it's
the same is crazy and then also the
whole thing of the we know people now we
now know this whether someone's got the
vax or not
firstly they can both get coded
secondly they've shown that got the same
viral viral load you can still get it
you can you can still spread it to other
people so on so this whole notion of
doing it to protect others doesn't even
make sense but people just keep
repeating it because they hear the word
vaccine and they equate them all if
you're talking about a sterilizing
vaccine there's a strong argument that
of course okay if it blocks transmission
then you cannot give it to someone else
so it has that effect if it doesn't do
that so-called leaky vaccine as
scientists call it then it protects you
and there's nothing wrong with
protecting yourself if i every time i
take a medicine it's a totally selfish
decision i've never i don't take
medicines for other people
[Music]
i take medicine because i'm feeling sick
and there's nothing wrong with that
right there's nothing wrong with um
selfish is one of those words that's
kind of funny because it's automatically
assumed as negative but it simply means
that you're doing something for yourself
and to protect yourself if i'm riding a
bike and i put a helmet on that's a
selfish decision it's to protect my head
it's not to protect anybody else but i
think that um you know people want to go
with this sort of hero and communitarian
narrative even when it doesn't really
make sense there's nothing wrong with
taking it if you're unwell if you're hey
i'm 70 you're someone's 70 and they're
diabetic and they're in rough shape and
covet is a genuine threat to them and
they're taking the shot to protect them
god bless you there's absolutely
absolutely nothing wrong with that and a
1 000 percent support your right to do
it my only issue
with this whole thing has been the
coercion the force the bullying the
shaming setting people against each
other all of that it's unnecessary it's
counterproductive and there's the other
element of it which is a censoring of
freedom of speech which they do online
particularly there are big tech
overlords whereby if you talk about
these subjects yeah prime example if you
talked uh a year ago that maybe the
virus might have been created in alabama
wuhan and then was elite accidentally
you would get your content taken down
absolutely and and now it's the most
credible version of events yeah i mean
it always was
it always was but this is the
this is the issue and look i'm just
interested in the truth i i don't i
don't have an agenda right i don't have
an agenda beyond wanting myself and
people to
be free and be able to live their lives
and run their businesses and go to work
and you know not be forced to do this
and that that's that's my only agenda if
you even want to call it that i just
want life to be like it was you know i
think people thought january 2020 was a
was a bad time but i think
we'd happily go back to that um that's
literally all that i advocate for i'm
for freedom of choice i'm for liberty
i'm for you know people just being
allowed to have their independence and
their civil liberties and
it's it's that simple for me
hey constantin do you like christmas no
in ussr we cancelled christmas and we
had lenin fest instead hosanna we
celebrated glorious leader and rewrote
story of jesus to make it better really
yes in our story three wise men were
killed and gifts meant for jesus
redistributed to glorious workers of the
soviet union jesus was put in gulag for
having wrong opinion as we call it in
russia happy ending
right well if you do want to celebrate
the festive season then there's only one
way to do it grab yourself a ticket to
our final live show of the year at the
leicester square theatre on saturday
december the 11th yes it is discussion
with one of our favorite guests aisha
akanbi she is almost as good philosopher
as vladimir lenin
yeah exactly our two previous shows sold
out completely and this one will as well
grab your ticket now before it's too
late click on link below during interval
there will be special entertainment i
will ride bear with my shirt off i
didn't realize we were going for that
demographic mate oh yes we are
well you talk about civil liberties and
i i initially was very in favor of
everything that was being done because i
was like we don't know what's going on
if if the scientists or the doctors are
telling us the lock down is is what
flattens the curve let i'm happy to go
along with that i wore masks for a
period of time but we've got to a point
now and and i'm going to preface this
with an identity politics point just to
soften the blow for people but my jewish
great grandfather died on the eastern
front fighting against fascism right
and i'm not saying where we are now in
austria and germany mandating vaccines
is the same as nazism i'm not saying
it's auschwitz i'm not saying any of
that
but what i'm saying is some people came
together in 1945 and what you know one
thing that we really shouldn't do
is force people to take medical
procedures that they don't want
right
and we seem to have just
very casually
just walked across that line in several
countries now where
it's just like being talked about and
as it was fascism the majority of the
public support it exactly but this is
the thing see something that's been
really annoying with this especially
coming from people who
spent the past four years calling uh you
know the truth everyone is trump hitler
and everyone who voted for begs in a
nazi or whatever is that they're now
saying that oh you're not allowed to
compare anything to to nazi germany or
to even you know stalinist russia etc
and
you know number one i just reject that
like if you cannot make comparisons then
what's the point of
knowing that history if you're not
allowed to point out when there are
certain things that are echoing it no
one is directly comparing this to the
holocaust itself as in the extermination
of jewish people but if you are looking
at the nazi germany didn't begin with
the holocaust right if you're looking at
the discrimination and segregation and
mistreatment and the use of state and
the use of the media to turn people
against certain segments of the
population you can absolutely compare it
you can compare it to what happened in
rwanda in 1994. i've heard from friends
in germany in austria that their media
is really really demonizing people who
haven't taken the shot like they're you
know people are actually making charges
of hate speech against actual media
channels because they're going that
intensely with their rhetoric and it's
just like
stop
stop and not only is is what you're
firstly what you're saying it's not it's
not even logically coherent it doesn't
make any logical sense
because again these are not sterilizing
vaccines right they had to change the
definition of vaccine in fact for this
to even fit into them that's why i
typically call them jabs or injections
it's not your neighbor who is
your enemy or who's spread it it doesn't
make any sense you can look at places
like ireland gibraltar israel where
they've got super high vax rates and
they're still getting all these
infections and so on um it doesn't it
doesn't make sense and also
you know i think people need to
i think people need to really just
exhale
and chill out do you know what i mean i
think it's been it's been two years it's
been 600 plus days of fear and
propaganda and narrative and media and
this and this and just just hammering
people
non-stop and i think that people do
for the most part want to get out of it
but when you demoralize people and you
break their spirit and you make them
feel like i will do you put them in a
desperate situation where it's like okay
i will do anything
even if it's
unethical even if it means
breaking up my family or my friendship
groups or my relationship with my
countrymen etc if this gets us out of it
let's do it and again we've seen this
throughout history
right that's part of you know nazi
germany didn't start in a vacuum it
started post world war one things were
very desperate the economy was depend
you know someone came with a message and
um i imagine i wasn't around but i
imagine a lot of the germans didn't like
some of the
anti-semitic rhetoric and the stuff like
that but the other stuff they were kind
of on board with so they were like
yeah you know i'll hold my nose and go
with this guy
even though he seems a little bit weird
on this and then again over time the the
maybe it was the chase
yeah the slow escalation and you know
all of that frustration and anger can be
directed towards these people and and
look i think
the point is not to
be
i want to be very clear i'm not trying
to be disrespectful to anybody who
actually has
family members ancestors who suffered
under these i'm not trying to minimize
anything here i'm simply saying that
history doesn't repeat but it rhymes it
echoes
and human beings have not fundamentally
changed
over this time period so humans and this
is a really dark thing but it's real
people are still capable of all the
awful things that have happened in
history
human beings are still capable of them
so when we start trending in these
negative directions i think it's
important to call it out to nip it in
the bud and say look guys no
segregation bat
right we've we've done this before we've
done jim crow in america apartheid in
south africa there are other examples
we've done this before where we
say this group of the population is not
allowed to enter here or does not have
the same rights of these people that's
been done before a lot
it's not it's not a good idea
ultimately it ends in violence it ends
in blood bloodshed
it's it's it's not good and we can
totally avoid this and doing this for a
virus with a 99.9 plus survival rate in
most of the population
extra silly right
extra stupid right if we were dealing
with some great plague level event
still bad
but
it would at least be like okay i can
really understand why people are so
you wouldn't need to do a zoo if this
was a virus
with a 40 survival rate everybody would
take any sort of vaccine that was often
you wouldn't need you wouldn't you
wouldn't have the only reason you need
the authoritarianism is that a lot of
people realize this virus is mostly not
dangerous exactly and this is the thing
two years in again
i give people a lot of grace right so
i'm someone who from very early i saw
stuff being weird earlier than most
people but i told i can i can clearly
remember february and march last year
right so i can understand
the fear and their spot but as you get
as you get more inputs you get more
information you get more data
you your position should
change and i think that's happened with
a lot of people there's a lot of people
who you know were whoa okay at the
beginning i was really freaked out but
you know by summer i was like okay wait
i'm not seeing
everybody dying around me i'm not seeing
bodies in the street i'm not seeing you
know
i haven't lived through like a super
scary mega deadly pandemic i mean
but from what i understand of ones in
history it's like okay you there's no
you don't need advertising
you don't need pr you're not you don't
need to try to scare people you know you
you actually need to try to calm people
down because they're so fearful just
from what they're seeing with their own
eyes but for most people
it's like okay you've been we're two
years into this and you're you can you
know you can have in your head that this
is
whatever you've led to believe it in
your head but your eyes
are not
feeding this information
to you right you're not
you're you're not
really living in reality here so i think
with a lot of people now they have this
kind of schism between what they want to
believe i think i think this is also why
and i made this point before this is the
first virus in history
where people want it to be worse than it
is
which is really interesting people want
it to be worse than it is because that
would confirm their world view and it
would validate their behavior for the
past two years right because otherwise
they just look like a crazy person
and i think that's why you know when
maybe one of us makes certain cup
it it angers people or when you give
people actual stats
right of survivability or it not being a
big threat to children and so on people
actually get angry
because you are
causing the schism
in their brain where they are acting as
if they're living through the black
death and then you're like man you know
for most people it's kind of like a flu
we interviewed a
doctor called dr john white who made the
point that
we don't actually know the long-term
effects of the virus okay so that's a
one place where you could say
maybe we should try and reduce
transmission as much as possible because
we don't know the long-term effects
here's my thing man every everyone's
going to get it
almost everyone's going to get it
and i assume this from the very
beginning it's a coronavirus it's like
trying to live your entire life never
getting a colder flu you can't do it it
just doesn't work it's always mutating
there's so many vectors both human and
animal vectors
and it's it's just there so you've had
covet yep you've had covet i've had
covet it's only been two years we have
all three friends
all three of us have
already i've already had it right so
it's going to get to most people that's
that's just the reality of it and so
that's why i think with what they're
doing in places like australia and new
zealand is particularly um near-sighted
because right now sure maybe their um
their their death numbers might look
good now but does anyone there have
natural immunity
right well i guess their argument is if
if they can keep any outsiders out long
enough they can vaccinate everybody
uh and then everybody's got some
immunity against covert and that way you
reduce the deaths
from covet maybe you reduce the deaths
from great
maybe maybe that would depend greatly on
the efficacy
of the vaccines especially with more and
more variants coming out et cetera um
but again it comes back to our point of
like okay well what are what about all
the other i agree caused by it right so
so so so that's the thing and you know
it's a balance and again throughout all
of this thing one one thing that i've
been very
in favor of is simply discussion
right
the amount of doctors and scientists
that have been
silenced or censored or pushed to the
side or just everyday people
all of this all this conversation we're
having some of these questions we're
asking i don't know the answer to
everything i'm just asking i'm asking a
lot of questions and coming up with
ideas and someone might say oh well what
about this what about that this this
should have just been how it was
all the way through from the beginning
because again you have to remember the
models that they started how many deaths
did they predict in the uk was it
if if nothing was done if no
restrictions were put in half a million
was going to die yeah half a million to
a million u.s they predicted three to
four million
okay
um
that was off
right that was that was off and you know
someone might say oh well it's because
it's because we did the measures
we don't know it's always hard to you
know we don't we don't really have the
counterfeit i mean i personally would
argue the vaccines have definitely
reduced the number of people who have
died i'm sorry look i'm i think i'm i'm
not i'm not against i'm not against any
vaccination right i think having as many
options as possible vaccinations various
types of treatments etc it should all be
it should all be available right i don't
i don't have the arrogance to assume
that i know the best thing for
absolutely everyone or that i know
everyone's medical history and all these
details about them again like i'm i'm 35
years years old i'm in great shape i've
already had covet i've got strong
i've got strong natural naturally
acquired immunity
my position is not the same as an 80
year old who hasn't had covet and
perhaps has one or two comorbidities
and it's not the same as a 10 year old
child who's just perfectly healthy and
bouncing around and happy so to treat
all of these people with one size fits
all
is is crazy i mean you know i like i
like peanut butter
but if i were to mandate peanut butter
that's genocide look at him look at his
face he hates it okay yeah but it won't
kill you
no but i hate but but people would kill
you
okay but there but there are there are
millions of people that you you can
could be killed by a couple of people so
that that's just an example of you know
the human body is complicated man
penicillin has saved tons of lives
there's people you can kill with
penicillin absolutely right all
different people respond differently to
different medicines different foods
we've known this forever that's not
that's nothing controversial so that's
again why when it comes to things like
mandates
i'm like this is that's psychotic
right you're going to kill some people
you are
if you take a billion people and you
mandate anything
any medical injury you you are going to
kill some people and that is why it must
always remain a choice
right that's why it must always remain a
choice i think that there are segments
of the population and demographics where
totally totally makes sense for them
it's reasonable even if i don't think it
makes sense for them or whatever
if you're an adult hey that that's
that's your choice and then you assume
the risk on both sides right there is
risk on both sides you assume it and
that equation is not the same for
everybody my personal view i think that
giving these injections to children is
psychotic
i i think i think it's reckless right
because
the risk of the disease is close to zero
in terms of severe disease let alone
death it's close to zero we know that
we've got data from every country in the
world for two years we know that okay
the effect of the
of the jabs on them we don't we do not
know we do not know they're still in
trial even for healthy adults up until
2022 2023
um but for kids we we simply do not know
so for me in my personal opinion
that doesn't make sense again they do
not block the transmission so you can't
even make the argument that okay give it
to kids to protect
you shouldn't be using kids to protect
adults anyway well exactly like look
we'll have to wrap up but the very basic
point you've made is there's risks to
everything yes and if you're mandating
vaccines for children statistically
speaking that is going to have a
negative impact and i'm just gonna i'm
not gonna go into the details of it for
youtube purposes but it's gonna have a
negative impact on some of those kids
statistically speaking that's a fact yes
if you mandated peanut butter for all
the children in the world some of them
would die yes what do you think about it
like i'm i'm not going to get into the
details of it but that's a fact right so
you haven't it's that philosophical
question that we always talk about if
you could save a million people by
killing one innocent child would you
um
that's that's that's the conversation
right i don't think that's the
conversation don't you no
no i think that's a false analogy why
because you're talking about a mandate
but that's exactly what i'm saying but
what yeah yeah it is mandate will
no but what i'm saying is that without
the mandate yeah look everyone who
wanted the jab took it without a mandate
yeah fact
yeah right everyone who wanted it took
it beyond any mandate or bizarre
incentives or whatever and that's that's
it that should be the finish line
everyone who wants it has had a chance
to get it yeah what i'm saying is i'm
agreeing with you i think we're
mishearing each other
if you mandate a vaccine for children or
if you mandate peanut butter for
children if you mandate whatever for
children
in order to protect other people because
as you say we know children are not
vulnerable to the virus
right if you were doing that you were in
you are knowingly saying
we are going to hurt some some kids
in order to protect some other people to
me that's a moral yeah that's immoral i
agree and also it's and also it's not
correct in this case right because it's
not a sterilizing vaccine yeah yeah
before we do our last question
i'm going to ask you this question i
know what the answer's gonna be but i
want to ask you anyway zooby
do you think we're gonna go back to and
i hate this term
inverted commas the old normal
yes but i think it depends on the people
i think it's this ends when this ends
when people decide it does for indiv
both on an individual and a societal
level it ends when you end it
and do you think we're going to end it
depends on the country
okay some places never started some
places i don't have much hope for
okay so let's see what places do you
have hope for which places do i hope
hope for i have hope for virtually every
republican-led state in the usa
i have hope for much of africa i have
hope for much of south america
um
europe has certain pockets which i have
hoped for but overall
many parts of western europe
canada australia new zealand
i
i think people are have i think too many
people are welcoming in the new regime i
think that if you are a liberty-minded
person
you should be doing your best to get out
of those countries that's my personal
view it's actually been my view of the
past year
zooby we've got last question for you as
always which is what's the one thing no
one's talking about that
oh yeah uh i think i went real
controversial on the last one so
funnily enough
i think it's health
i think actual health
i'm not just talking about masks and
jabs i mean actual health i think it's
been
a catastrophe
that this time period has not been used
to really talk about the
obesity epidemic
and all of the health problems which
have merely been magnified
by the covid situation i think this
would have been the perfect time to
really sound this message especially in
countries like the uk and usa where
obesity rates have just been
skyrocketing
i think that the lack of conversation
about nutrition about exercise lifestyle
changes generally living a healthy life
and looking after
your own body and taking that individual
personal responsibility
i think that's really been lacking i
think it's been lacking for several
decades
and
yeah this would have been the perfect
opportunity so i think not enough as
much as people are talking about health
not enough people are truly talking
about
the full scope of health all right but
we're going to ask you questions from
our local supporters uh which are
separate but for now thanks so much for
coming on uh where can people find you
online sure i'm on all social media at
zubi music that is zuby music i'm on
instagram facebook twitter
youtubeminds.com
and you can find me at zoobymusic.com
where i've got links to my podcast my
merchandise everything else all right
man thanks for coming back on the show
really appreciate it and thank you so
much for watching and listening we will
see you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or raw show all of
them go out at 7 p.m uk time and if you
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below